I feel like ever deserves their second
chance people always have given me
trouble for going to clubs so why don't
I just open my own boss [ __ ] word of
this whole idea of hey up and open a
beach club come from where does that
come from and why do you decide to do it
in Mykonos
well I started with the nightclub in
Athens and because I wanted to open
doors up to people having fun and going
out at night and I love music and I love
entertaining so I said well I love the
beach and I'd rather do something in the
day now so mikonos was convenient same
partners how about I add like about a
dozen really hot Tony's
18 year olds into the mix that's an
interesting idea well because I wanted
to bring people from America into to
share this experience that I'm having
with this wonderful beach house and and
I thought if we're gonna do it we might
as well do it right and make it more
interesting and put these kids to the
tests to work for me you have to be the
best of the best I want to build an
empire here
did you know that you are we gonna
become like a mother hen right away yeah
I wanted to be protective of them and I
also want them to have fun but not too
much and that's really hard to maintain
because I also need them to show up and
be on point and present and I want to
know their stories like I'm not just
gonna bring someone there and know
nothing about them I want you want a
little good people and so that comes a
lot into play yeah yeah I think at one
point you said in the episode I know
what it's like yeah I mean everyone can
everyone relates on some level sometimes
in life on different things that I
really wanted to be a guiding voice for
that do you watch Vanderpump rules yes
because you know there's these
comparisons now with you and Lisa van
well she's inspiring Lisa I just saw her
actually did you yeah and and she's a
dear friend of mine so we're kind of
this is like the Young's a baby version
look at the junior version in a way but
it's true I mean that I think that's a
great strong woman yes lady and I and I
really admired that about her have you
asked her for any advice and trying to
do this and and really build an empire
I'll be asking her a lot more now cuz
this is the first time that I'm even
trying to figure out what to do with the
VIP hosts so that was kind of difficult
and confusing too because and now I know
now I know that they have to be assigned
specific things in different tasks but
this is we're just figuring it out and
it's the first year that the beach house
is open you're no stranger to drama so
how much drama will we see this season
on the show well a lot but but for me
it's it's the cameras flip so I'm I'm
kind of depicting how much drama a
little held us and then but yeah there's
and it's these I mean they're in Mykonos
it's their first time in Mykonos coming
from America and so that in itself and
enough and they're on camera now so
everybody's different and I see that and
I I recognize that
[Music]
[Applause]